esta grabación de una cámara corporal
revela los últimos momentos de la vida
de adam rowley de un niño de 13 años de
edad fue publicada este jueves y muestra
al oficial eric hillmán persiguiendo por
un callejón al niño de origen hispano en
las primeras horas del 29 de marzo
hillmán ordena toledo que enseñe las
manos al sospechar que el adolescente
lleva un arma menos de un segundo antes
de ser disparado en el pecho toledo
parece levantar las manos un fiscal dijo
que el niño estaba armado pero en el
vídeo no se ve ningún arma en sus manos
el oficial le gritó muéstrame las manos
arma con fire adam cumplió y se dio la
vuelta sus manos estaban vacías cuando
el oficial le disparó en el pecho
la policía fue llamada al barrio
mexicano de little village de chicago
tras recibir informes de disparos en la
zona las imágenes muestran a la policía
en el lugar de los hechos atendiendo
médicamente a toledo mientras un agente
alumbra con una linterna un objeto
cercano
la alcaldesa de chicago ha pedido a la
población que no emita juicios hasta
que se complete la investigación y más
canciones debemos afrontar la verdad y
no ignorar el hecho de que chicago así
como demasiadas partes de nuestro país
tiene un largo legado de violencia
policial y mala conducta policial que ha
dejado demasiados residentes
especialmente los que son afroamericanos
y latinos y un estado constante de miedo
y dolor la publicación del vídeo se
produce poco después del tiroteo de down
rights un hombre afroamericano durante
un control de tráfico cerca de
minneapolis el domingo la muerte del
joven de 20 años ha provocado protestas
cada noche de esta semana en minneapolis
también se celebra el juicio contra el
ex policía de vex joven acusado de
asesinar al también afroamericano
georges floyd